all right people we are live and this is
a very special evening edition
of the reuben report i'm dave rubin and
jesus christ i just sat through that
debacle my god you see how he did the
image there that's i'll try to keep my
head in case you're you know you're
probably sick of the guy already i'll
try to do this the whole time what was
that
every word of it was just an endless lie
and obfuscation of the truth and and to
do 45 minutes before you got into covid
and to watch all these geriatric people
hug and kiss and not socially distance
and ever just the hypocrisy the endless
[ __ ] all of it like
jesus
i was watching with my entire team and
everyone it's like it's like the the
show seems like it's not working anymore
that's what it felt like like we're all
supposed to sort of believe in the show
and the show just kind of broke down i
will give credit however where credit is
due that is what i like to do and uh joe
biden although he slurred over words
probably every other sentence he didn't
have any major malfunctions there was
one moment where everyone thought he was
going to completely lose it but then the
the system kind of rejiggered itself and
he he didn't have a complete breakdown
uh but whatever they inject him with or
they put adderall in his metamucil or
whatever they do that kind of worked and
you know they had a lot of makeup on him
and he looked tan and all that good
stuff so look we're just going to roll
through some of the clips uh you know
some of the fumbles some of the quasi
sensible statements that he made i
suppose but the
the overarching thing that just happened
of
you know this idea
that we're going to talk about war for
the first half hour basically we're not
getting into war but here are all the
reasons that we might get into war
um and that we didn't talk about covid
until the end and that it just it's just
over they're just they're just doing it
they're doing it right in front of our
faces it's just over folks it's over
they're saying it's over and we're on to
war now or we're on to not war war
something like that anyway i do hope
that you are drinking something or at
least we're drinking something during
some of that if you were doing shots
every time he slurred a word you are
absolutely wasted you are probably
unconscious right now i am rocking
the clausal reposado this is the good
stuff people it ain't cheap it's the
good stuff
and it was keeping me going through this
thing you know i really try like look
this is what i do for a living i love
politics i love the
the gamesmanship and all of this i love
talking about ideas and fighting for
what i believe in and all of the stuff i
do you know that i do that's why you
watch this show i i love trying to
translate some of the lunacy into
something that you guys can make sense
of and take into your lives and i try to
do it in a fun way so that it's not
endlessly painful but everything that we
just heard really all of it from top to
bottom i missed the last two minutes so
maybe in the last two minutes you really
tied the thing together and it made a
lot of sense but it was just like lie
and nonsense after
uh one statement after the next just
endless endless so let's we just grabbed
a bunch of clips i haven't reviewed them
yet but i was watching them so we were
just kind of grabbing them on the fly
here's a little bit that
he got right to right out of the gate
about russia and ukraine and i think
there might have been a little slip up
in there
our forces are not
engaged and will not engage in the
conflict with russian forces in ukraine
our forces are not going to europe to
fight ukraine but to defend our nato
allies in the event that putin decides
to keep moving west
okay well i'm glad we're not going to
europe to fight ukraine i guess we got
that worked out we are not going to bomb
the hell out of the ukrainian forces
he thought we were on their side but
joe's a little confused about that
obviously he meant to say we're not
going to there to fight russia although
that was a little bit odd because
everything else in the next half hour of
his speech was how we are trying to
destroy russia whether through sanctions
or what we're going to do to the
oligarchs or we're going to take away a
rich guy's pool and yacht and a whole
bunch of other stuff
here's more on air travel and russia
the united states
department of justice is assembling a
dedicated task force to go after the
crimes of the russian oligarchs
we're joining with european allies to
find and seize their yachts their luxury
apartments their private jets
we're coming for you or ill-begotten
gains and tonight
i'm announcing that we will join our
allies in closing off american air space
to all russian flights further isolating
russia
and adding additional squeeze on their
economy
we're coming after their yachts and
their ill-begotten gains
uh
joe
joe
oh my other side you see this lady
pretty sure she's got a couple yachts
and she definitely has ill-begotten
gains so you better be careful when you
talk about the oligarchs the people who
have profited endlessly off the
taxpayers
you're talking of course about the
people in russia but they're doing it
right here at home there she is
nancy by the way did keep her dentures
in for the entire talk unless i missed
it in the last two minutes it was
she's always sucking on the dentures but
she did not lose her dentures and kamala
no that's kamala kamala very little uh
cackling she was she was pretty much
under control so that was pretty good uh
but this thing with russia
which again this was the bulk of this
thing was about russia
until three days ago or say five days
ago how much of your life you person
watching this right now how much your of
your life was really being affected by
russia but we just did
75 percent of a state of the union where
all we talked about was russia and what
we can do to oligarchs in russia and the
mean man who's running russia now i'm
not defending putin and you can't just
invade other nations and all of that
stuff and you shouldn't be killing
innocent civilians etc etc that all goes
without saying but this was the state of
the union of the united states the
purpose of this is to say here's where
we're at here's where we're going here
are the policies we have in place so
that americans can prosper and mostly
this was saber-rattling
about russia and it was also bizarre
because even though he said uh we're not
gonna bomb the ukraine you know ukraine
right we're not gonna bomb ukrainian
troops and things like that and even
though he meant to say russians
it's like well at the same time joe uh
you basically threaten them for a half
hour so what do you think putin's
takeaway of that thing was you know if
if you just understand basic game theory
here and you don't like what putin is
doing and we're laying some sanctions
and they're going to maybe kick rush off
the swift financial system and all of
those things putin needs an off-ramp
right he needs some way if you don't
want to go to nuclear war because the
guy's got nukes if you don't want him to
just feel that he's completely cornered
has to do something else you have to
give him some off-ramp and that speech
was extremely threatening actually it
sort of i think the way they try to make
it come off is that joe's being nice
somehow and he's really you know he's
just fighting for democracy and we're
doing all these things that we're gonna
take away their yachts
in the name of democracy um
but that's not really the way i think a
guy like putin may take it or if you
were just really listening like it was
it was a pretty threatening speech and
again what does this have to do with the
state of the union of the united states
what does this have to do with how much
money you have in your bank account or
your roads or anything else now look he
did get to some of that
stuff later and in most cases notice he
meant nothing about tax cuts really it's
always oh the rich have to pay their
fair share yeah they pay the top one
percent pay something like 55 of all
taxes so okay who decides what their
fair share is and it's all just that the
government guys if the government just
needs more of your money you know after
two years at covid oh and he was very
proud what was it six and a half million
jobs is that what he said i think it was
six and a half million new jobs this
year uh but most all times something
like that it's like dude
do you remember what happened the year
before when you locked all these people
down and forced people to to leave their
jobs and not go to work and everything
else they j and these clowns these seals
clapping for everything here here's a
little more on biden and taxpayer
dollars to rebuild america and tonight
i'm announcing that this year
we will start fixing over 65 000 miles
of highway and 1
500 bridges in disrepair
and folks
when we use
taxpayers dollars to rebuild america
we're going to do it by buying america
buy american products
support american jobs
the federal government
spends about 600 billion a year to keep
this country safe and secure
there's been a law on the books for
almost a century to make sure taxpayers
dollars support american jobs and
businesses
every administration democrat and
republican says they'll do it
but we're actually we're actually doing
it
we'll buy america to make sure every
everything from the deck of an aircraft
carrier to the steel on highway guard
rails is made in america from beginning
to end all of it all
you know i'm old enough folks to
remember just two short years ago and
two short years ago when you talked
about buying america
and supporting america
and america america
making america great again that was
racist wasn't that racist stuff when you
did that two years ago there was a
certain orange man who talked about that
america first we should take care of our
borders uh we should take care of our
economy look after our people first that
was all thought of as racist stuff and
now they just repeat it and these clowns
clap for it speaking of clowns clapping
there was this funny moment with chuck
schumer when he accidentally clapped
when he wasn't supposed to clap and then
he realized he was clapping he was
pre-clapping rescue plan
[Music]
the american rescue plan
helped working people and left no one
behind
are they robots like are they robots is
chuck schumer a male
functioning robot and these old bastards
and i don't mean that to be ageist i
hope i get old one day but these old
mother
effers
see i did it guys uh
with tequila which is not easy to
control the f-bombs on tequila um
who did all of this abuse to children
who dare show up there and as i said
earlier the hugging and the kissing each
other and they applaud like seals and
it's like it all it's a bad script it's
like writers of this horrific truman
show were in can you get new material or
something although i'm a little afraid
what new material will look like because
that'll probably involve a uh involve a
war um he kept saying that we have to
lower costs
not wages and they kept applauding that
um that doesn't mean anything really
think about that i mean lower costs okay
so if you want lower cost that means you
want goods you want your bottle of
klazazul tequila
your glass from cb2 and your fancy ice
maker that gives you the big ice cube
you want those things to be cheaper
right so lower costs now how would you
lower costs you would lower costs by
lowering the expenses that businesses
have to make products right uh that way
which in essence means that if you cut
taxes then they can buy things more
cheaply they can afford to pay their
employees more so they have more money
and that's basically what keeps the
economy going
lower cost not wages it makes it's
nothing it's just words that he puts
together and they all applaud it lower
costs out wages well if you lower taxes
then you will lower costs if you lower
taxes then you will raise wages because
companies have more money to pay more
people and give bigger bonuses and hire
more people and everything else
everything they just say is nonsense and
then the other one of course and it's
like man if you're a parent after two
years of covid and sending your kids to
school to be abused and brainwashed into
critical race theory and the rest of
this woke nonsense when they talk about
cutting the cost of child care
let's put the cost side away what he's
saying is we want more of your children
in government-run schools to learn that
boys or girls and girls are boys and
racism is good and white people are bad
and all of the rest of the nonsense why
would you be listening to that and going
oh that's just wonderful i can send my
child to a brainwashing center even
cheaper and then later he also said you
know and i know some of you have
children under five and you want your uh
child to get vaccinated and the
scientists are working on that and it's
like yes okay that really uh is making a
lot of sense there was a study out today
i hope i'm loosely quoting it correctly
that for children 5 to 11 the vaccine is
basically 12
effective please fact check me on that
media matters losers i'm sure you're
watching uh it was roughly right um
like who i just can't imagine i honestly
cannot imagine how you could be a parent
two years into this thing and you're
sitting there listening to this nonsense
from joe biden and then you're oh my god
we're gonna not have to pay as much to
send our kids to the brainwashing center
where they're gonna then get injected
with the stuff that the scientists who
lied to us about everything are gonna do
and the whole freaking thing
all right dave dave
try to try to be positive try to be a
little positive was there anything in
there i guess i could throw to some
locals comments while i try to think of
anything roughly anything in there that
made sense uh diplodys over at
rubinreport.locals.com said funny how he
said we need to buy american and all
those tests were purchased from china
isn't that something how the tests are
purchased from china and all of the
masks and the ppe and all that stuff
purchased from china remember that yeah
very
very bizarre uh g8 says okay so he said
god protect our troops and go get him
are we [ __ ] going to war yeah that's
why the war part of this
again you got to admire the system and i
i don't mean to repeat myself but allow
me to repeat myself you got to give the
devil as due we we just dealt with two
years of covid and then they flipped the
script so quickly so that that old
senile buffoon could get up there and
read that speech and for 40 minutes
pretend that kovit didn't even exist and
then it was just a throwaway at the end
while they didn't wear masks and
everything else um are we going to war i
don't know i i have no idea to me that
sounded like a war speech it wasn't a
war speech like we're psyched to go to
war and we're going to invade your
country and everything else but as i
said earlier it's sort of like if you're
putin and you're listening to that it's
like they're coming after you man they
are coming after you obviously so what
what is the message that putin is gonna
get that's not that's not taking putin's
side that's just reality there's reality
to politics there's reality to the
geopolitical world and and how humans
interact you know you don't have to
understand every little in and out of
the history of russia and ukraine and
nato and the united states relationship
to all this to understand how world
actors behave how people behave when you
corner people so that speech to me
ramped up the chances of war more than
anything else and that's what it seemed
to do
in my mind at least
lenny says everything is free free and
taxes are going down yeah it's
extraordinary how they do this they
raise taxes constantly right this is
what the democrats do they always raise
taxes they also then blame the people
who are the job creators so they blame
in industry they blame tech they blame
companies that build things they always
want more of their money as we know elon
musk pays more in taxes than anybody
else but they always want more and more
and more
and then they'll tell you that stuff is
free and this is what we're going to
give you and it's like it's your money
it's not their money until we get that
simple fact across to people and that's
made in some ways the scariest fact to
the machine it's the one thing the
machine if the machine didn't want you
to know one thing it's that it's your
money in the first place and if more
people i guess had a physical paycheck
these days you know we do everything
online but if more people you know you
got the mail the way it was in the old
days or on a friday you'd go down to
accounting and you'd pick up your check
and you looked at your check and you
really looked and go well wait a minute
i was supposed to make 500 bucks this
week turns out i only made 260 because
blah blah blah and they took this out
and that you might start going well
where is all this money going and then
and then you know okay we're going to
what did he say we're going to give a
billion dollars to ukraine or something
next week it's like i don't know could
we maybe use a billion dollars around
here perhaps money that we don't have
anyway since we don't have any money
we're a debtor nation that's what we are
uh my guys are giving me an update on
something i said before uh vaccinated
children is 12 for transmission which is
still terrible what does that mean 12
for transmission
the tr okay so if you're vaccinated the
chance that you can transmit covid
is 12
which is pretty freaking low so that
ain't good
yeah
do you get it guys do you get it we have
just been bludgeoned over the head with
this lunacy uh should we throw it
anything else with locals i think i've
made the point i know this is a short
live stream but i think i think i've
made the point tonight with these people
yeah god i don't know what to do i don't
know what to do i need to sleep on it
really i need to sleep on
like what
what are we supposed to do to to make
some sense out of this like so many
people you're going to watch the
mainstream media be rooting for war now
you could already feel it but now
there'll be this sort of march to war
um they're just going to stop talking
about kobit they're they're going to
blame the people who shouldn't be blamed
it's uh it's very it's very bizarre but
i don't want to end on that
solemn note i want to end with something
funny so right before we started uh the
stream here i saw this video it's
actually absolutely hilarious this is a
local news i think it's from today take
a look it's not clear what may have been
taken and no arrests have been made a 71
year old man is accused of
inappropriately touching a 12-year-old
girl at the walmart in west mifflin
sunday afternoon
see so it wasn't a total bust tonight we
at least got that
i enjoyed the pizza tonight did you guys
enjoy the pizza the pizza was good i had
this like we had some sort of pizza it
had pepperoni and coffee on it really
delicious really delicious so look
biden can say oh that's not american
made i don't know we bought it in
america i don't know where the recipe
was from but i'm still a damn good
american and so are these fine gentlemen
thank you for watching we're back
tomorrow 11 a.m we'll try to get some
more clips of what happened i suppose or
we'll just maybe move on you want to
just maybe move on tomorrow we'll just
find something else to do all together
because like what more can i add to this
what are you watching right now
what else could you watch that's gonna
add any insight whatever you were
thinking while you were watching that
thing you were right
you were right i just know it i did
nobody no sane person was watching that
thing going oh man this guy knows what's
going on like the slurring all the all
the stuff
but nobody could have been watching that
thinking oh we're in good shape or this
is this is sort of congruent to a
reality that i've lived in in the past
two years
they're not good at what they're doing
the writers the script people all of
them get better guys that's my little
tip to you
all right goodnight everybody